aujourd'hui dans le cadre de l'interview
face cachée que je fais avec les
candidats à l'élection présidentielle
jeanne d'arc joue marine le pen marine
le pen est la candidate du rassemblement
national et c'est déjà la troisième fois
qu'elle se présente à cette élection en
2012 elle était arrivée en troisième
position avec près de 17% des voix et
bien en 2017 il ya cinq ans elle s'était
qualifié pour le second tour en
récoltant 21 3% des voix un second tour
où elle a été battue par ml le maquereau
qui avait obtenu 66 % des voir marine le
pen s'est engagé dès ses 18 ans dont le
parti d'extrême droite cofondé à à
l'époque par son père jean marie le pen
ça s'appelait donc le front national un
parti qui a changé depuis 2018 pour
s'appeler le rassemblement national elle
a été élue à plusieurs fonctions depuis
1998 conseillère régionale députée
européenne et aujourd'hui elle est
député depuis 2010 est le principe de
l'interview aux faces cachées je vous le
rappelle marine le pen fait face un
écran géant sur lequel défilent des
émaux j plusieurs fois pendant
l'interview elle appuie sur le buzzer
pour s'arrêter sur un et mogi dont la
face cachée va révéler différents
éléments qui seront à chaque fois vous
allez le voir le pont de départ de
questions de fond concernant son
programme et concernant sa vision de la
france alors c'est parti n'était pas en
tout cas à vous abonner à cette chaîne
youtube pour ne pas rater les
différentes interviews qui vont arriver
dans les prochains jours ainsi que les
présentations des programmes et je vous
laisse du coup avec l'interview bonjour
marine le pen bonjour merci d'avoir
accepté mon invitation est ce que les
règles générales sont claires je pense
que j'ai tout compris jusqu'ici du coup
tout va bien je propose pour commencer
d'appuyer sur deux heures et on va
pouvoir débuter avec la première
question ou le premier élément c'est
donc un est logique qu'ils représentent
une silhouette on va voir concrètement
ensemble ce qui se cache derrière
c'est une carte d'identité je précise
que elle est effective évidemment c'est
une carte d'identité d'une personne
je vous invite à voir notamment la date
de naissance elle est née le 16 février
1992 ça fait écho à quelque chose dans
votre programme sa date de naissance à
son année de naissance plus précisément
est ce que vous arrivez à avoir oui bien
sûr alla elle a donc moins de temps en
temps elle a 30 ans désormais et c'est
quelque chose d'assez important par
rapport à votre programme puisque vous
proposer dans le programme que
dessous de l'âge de 30 ans aucun
français ne paie d'impôt sur le revenu
le principe général de l'impôt sur le
revenu c'est que aujourd'hui c'est un
impôt qui est progressif donc plus vous
gagnez d'argent plus vous payez en
théorie là avec une telle mesure sa vie
un petit peu changé
tout ça est ce que c'est quelque chose
de juste selon vous oui parce qu'ils
juste c'est qu'en réalité tout ceux qui
ont moins de 30 ans paie pas d'impôts
voilà parce que je veux c'est que les
jeunes français
restent en france je veux qu'ils
construisent leur vie je veux qu'ils
puissent engager par exemple
des investissements s'il pense que c'est
nécessaire et donc j'ai dit tous les
moins de 30 ans ne paieront pas d'impôts
sur le revenu je vois trop de jeunes
aujourd'hui qui disent moi je ne pense
qu'à une chose c'est si je suis mieux
payés c'est de partir à l'étranger je
pense que c'est une déperdition totale
d'énergie de vitalité j'ai besoin que
les jeunes restent en france travaillent
en france et accessoirement d'ailleurs
montrent aussi leur entreprise en france
c'est pour ça que j'ai également
exonérées d'impôt sur les sociétés tous
les jeunes créateurs d'entreprise avaya
des conditions pour éviter les abus de
moins de 30 ans pendant cinq ans parce
que je pense qu'ils apportent énormément
de richesse et le fait qu'ils s'en
aillent et bien c'est une très mauvaise
nouvelle pour le pays mais du bout c'est
pas bizarre que quelqu'un du co qui a
deux ans de moins mais qui gagnent
beaucoup plus payent pas d'impôts et
c'est vrai mais apprécions la règle est
connue de tous si vous voulez chacun
sait que jusqu'à 30 ans paillasse être
électrique et c'est aussi le moyen de
pouvoir se projeter dans l'avenir de se
dire que oui effectivement à partir
d'une certaine d'un certain âge je vais
payer d'impôts mais en attendant et bien
j'en profite pour éviter d'être un
jeunes précarisés parce qu'on parle
toujours de ceux qui gagnent très bien
leur vie mais enfin honnêtement les
moins de 30 ans qui gagne comme j'ai pu
entendre des mille et des cents segal
0,000001 % l'immense majorité des gens
qui ont moins de 30 ans eh bien ils
payent des impôts sur le revenu parce
qu'à partir de à peu près mille 300
euros ou payent des impôts ni quand on
est célibataire même si c'est peu il
n'en demeure pas moins que c'est le cas
et que donc ils sont une immense
majorité en fait à payer un impôt sur le
revenu sur tille pourrait faire autre
chose est sûre cette mesure justement je
le disais à l'instant le principe de
l'impôt sur le revenu aujourd'hui c'est
qu'il est progressif et beaucoup de
juristes estiment qu' une telle
proposition d'exonérer d'impôt les moins
de l'est moins d'impôt sur le revenu les
moins de 30 ans serait contraire à la
constitution avec ce principe notamment
d'égalité fiscale et ce principe donc de
redistribution des richesses avec
l'impôt comment est ce que vous comptez
faire non parce que en fait le conseil
constitutionnel réclame que la
différenciation qui est fait
correspondre à un objectif qui soit un
objectif précis moi mon objectif précis
c'est précisément d'éviter
l'expatriation des jeunes saïd
l'expatriation des jeunes ça nous coûte
très cher en réalité ça coûte très cher
la société parce que d'abord non bah ça
coûte une fortune parce que par exemple
lorsque tout ce que nous avons payé
voyez pour former des jeunes un lycéen
ça coûte 5500 euros par an à la
collectivité un étudiant ça coûte entre
12000 et 14000 euros par an à la
collectivité tous ces gens qui après
avoir fait des études s'en vont eh bien
c'est ce qu'on appelle une perte en
capital humain et puis il ya aussi tout
ce que nous perdons le manque à gagner
des cotisations notamment sociales des
gens qui ne travaillent plus en france
il quittera l ampleur ce phénomène
aujourd'hui de jeunes qui quittent la
france bah écoutez en tout cas les
expatriés de manière générale on doubler
dans les vingt dernières années les
jeunes dont on parle ici des jeunes qui
quittent la france pour aller chercher
des meilleurs salaires ou autre vous
serez d'accord avec moi pour dire que
c'est une infime minorité des jeunes la
grande majorité des jeunes restent en
france font leurs études en france puis
travail en france est le problème chez
beaucoup de ces jeunes là c'est un
problème de précarité qui est très
important précarité notamment lors des
études forcément sur le financement des
études sur le fait de devoir travailler
à côté pour financer ces études là c'est
un sujet qui est important pour nous on
en a beaucoup parlé notamment sur la
chaîne notamment dans le cadre du coc
vite pour faire comprendre cette
détresse et cette précarité de nombreux
étudiants et de jeunes d'ailleurs plus
généralement comment est ce que vous
comptez répondre à cette urgence là j'ai
répondu dans mon projet car j'ai
beaucoup de mesures à destination des
jeunes je veux dire les jeunes sont
vraiment considérer pour moi comme une
des priorités des années qui viennent
donc la première réponse c'est le
complément de revenus que je vais
accorder aux jeunes étudiants qui
travaillent ça ira jusqu'à ce sera 20 %
de leurs de leur salaire le salaire
qu'il gagne en faisant un travail à côté
de leurs études jusqu'à 200 euros et 30
% jusqu'à 300 euros pour les boursiers
ça c'est déjà la première chose que si
quelqu'un c'est un étudiant travaille à
côté de ces études l'état faisant
augmenter le salaire de 7 étudiants
c'est exactement de jusqu'à 200 euros
s'il n'est pas boursiers jusqu'à 300
euros si les boursiers de la même
manière sous l'oeil a pas que des
étudiants à l'université il ya aussi des
apprentis il ya aussi des alternants et
bien de la même manière je considère qu'
il faut augmenter les moyens qui leur
sont accordées d'indemnisation au moment
de leur formation donc là c'est une
augmentation de 230 euros par mois
qu'ils pourront toucher en plus de leurs
indemnités d'alternants ou en plus de
leurs indemnités de
d'apprentis donc c'est vraiment à une
incitation importantes d'abord au
travail et puis une forte lutte contre
l'injustice qui fait que les jeunes sont
aujourd'hui dans une situation de
précarité qui est difficile il ya aussi
un autre aspect dont on parle peu quels
logements notamment le logement étudiant
il n'y a pas assez de logements
étudiants dans notre pays donc je
souhaite
construire cent mille logements
étudiants sur le quinquennat c'est à
dire sur les cinq prochaines années si
vous êtes élu président il exactement et
parce que je pense que il faut donner un
contenu un avantage aux jeunes français
en france je mets en place la priorité
nationale à l'accès au logement social
pour les jeunes étudiants prendrais
surement en reparler de cette chaussure
la priorité nationale sachant que c'est
des mesures que vous n'aviez pas annoncé
jusqu'ici me semble qu'elle n'était pas
présente dans l'autre dans votre
programme j'en ai présenté le 2 mai pas
tout c'est vrai on va passer à la
question suivante je relance du coup la
roue et je vous laisse arrêtez avec le
buzzer quand vous le souhaitez pour
découvrir le prochain sujet la prochaine
question en l'occurrence c'est un hymne
au gie une bulle vous le voyez une
citation face affiché à l'écran c'est
une trace qui a été prononcée par une ou
un autre candidat à l'élection
présidentielle
est ce que vous arrivez à savoir déjà
qui a prononcé la phrase suivante
c'est effectivement une fresque a été
prononcée par par eric zemmour marine le
pen est une femme de gauche a été
prononcée par exe moore le 27 octobre
2021 lors d'un déplacement à biarritz
fois ce qu'il a dit ça déjà selon parce
que eric zemmour il un il a un projet
qui est très néo libérale et qu'il
considère que quand on s'intéresse à la
justice sociale on est de gauche il ne
peut pas concevoir que il pu en être
autrement moi je suis désolé j'ai
toujours une fibre sociale je considère
que le rôle d'un président de la
république ce n'est pas seulement d'être
au chevet de ceux qui n'ont pas besoin
qu'on les aide sert les grandes
entreprises du cac 40
les gros salaires les gros moyens comme
l'a fait d'ailleurs emmanuel macron en
supprimant lisf mais c'est surtout sur
la fortune voilà mais c'est surtout de
venir au soutien en aide de ceux qui
sont dans une situation de précarité et
de vulnérabilité
donc c'est une vision effectivement
radicalement différente qui nous sépare
donc vous voyez une différence vous
d'apprendre vue économique ce qu'on voit
aussi c'est qu'ils avaient quand même un
certain nombre de points communs oui
d'ailleurs il ya eu un certain nombre de
départs ces derniers jours deux cadres
du rassemblement national qui sont
partis rejoindre eric zemmour ce qui
montre qu'il ya une proximité sur
certains sujets notamment sur
l'immigration vous partagez énormément
de choses la fin du regroupement
familial la suppression du droit du sol
le durcissement des conditions de
naturalisation y en a beaucoup comme ça
qui sont en commun il ya quand même
beaucoup de proximité du coup entre vos
programmes aussi sortait assez raila
vote d'ailleurs la vraie question c'est
pourquoi est-ce qu'ils s'y présenter
puisque l'offre politique qu'il
considère lui comme prioritaires
c'est-à-dire l'offre politique sur
l'immigration est déjà présente et je
l'incarnent et jeunes incarnent depuis
très longtemps parce que sur ces sujets
là on a travaillé depuis très longtemps
voulait proposer une alliance quelle
plus value non mais il veut pas je veux
être président de l'arizona il a discuté
avec lui et j'en ai discuté avec lui au
moins de mars dernier il faut être
président de la république c'est à un
moment donné bon
je peins pas essayer de le convaincre
d'autres choses mais je dire la vraie
question c'est quelle plus value il
apporte alors que non seulement nous
défendons ses idées depuis longtemps
mais surtout nous sommes beaucoup plus
avancé dans la mise en oeuvre de ces
idées parce que vous le savez moi je
veux faire un référendum sur
l'immigration c'est à dire que je vais
soumettre un projet de loi et ce sont
les français qui vont voter pour bien
comprendre juste sur ce sujet là vous
voyez des points communs sur ce nombre
de sujets notamment sur les sujets
d'immigration mais une différence
majeure sur les sujets économiques pour
comprendre en deux mots là-dessus cette
différence comme à ce qu'elle se situe
selon vous vous définissez vous dites
que eric zemmour est un néo libéral
concrètement qu'est ce que ça veut dire
et comment est ce que vous vous opposez
à cette vision cela concrètement c'est
que le son projet économique ressemble
beaucoup plus à celui d' emmanuel macron
qu'à un projet national voilà la
proposition je voudrais juste un exemple
il fait une proposition en lisant plutôt
que d'augmenter les salaires comme je
souhaite le faire dans un rapport
gagnant-gagnant avec les entreprises lui
ce qu'il veut c'est permettre que
l'entreprise puisse verser 3 mois de
primes sans charge bon tout ça c'est
bien gentil mais en réalité à terme
qu'est ce qui va se passer bah à terme
les chefs d'entreprise ils vont
embaucher des gens à des salaires 20%
inférieure en disant vous inquiétez pas
vous aurez 3 peuvent trois mois de prime
mais pour vivre on peut pas vivre avec
un salaire inférieur de 20% à ce qu'ils
sont déjà aujourd'hui alors qu'ils sont
déjà très bas on va passer à la question
suivante on relance la roue et je
voulais s'appuyer quand vous le
souhaitez
c'est logique cadeaux alors ça peut
faire plaisir comme ça mais ce cadeau
vous allez le voir c'est une question si
bien dans d'une autre candidate à
l'élection présidentielle je vous
propose d'écouter cette question et
ensuite évidemment d'y répondre
marine le pen je pense que
ce dans les classes populaires qui
regardent votre côté se trompent parce
que vous n'êtes pas dans le camp des
travailleurs vous n'êtes pas dans le
camp des ouvriers parce que vous n'avez
jamais rien à dire contre l'exploitation
contre les cadences infernales parce que
vous n'êtes pas contre la propriété
privée capitaliste d'ailleurs vous
n'êtes pas contre le fait qu'on puisse
faire des profits avec la vie humaine
puisque vous êtes pour les brevets sur
les vaccins alors moi ma question 1
comme j'ai vu que vous aviez abandonné
l'objectif de la de revenir à la
retraite à 60 ans la question que je me
pose c'est quelle promesse faite aux
travailleurs vous allez encore abandonné
pendant cette campagne non c'était donc
pour donner le contexte était nathalie
arthaud la candidate du parti d'extrême
gauche lutte ouvrière qui se posent et
du cou à cette question oui mais
nathalie arthaud il faut pas qu'elles
prennent les français pour des idiots
qui savait si aujourd'hui je suis en
tête du vote des ouvriers c'est parce
que les ouvriers de la 40% au premier
tour je pense que ils ont parfaitement
compris qu'en réalité le seul programme
véritablement applicable à les défendre
c'est le mien notamment luttant contre
la concurrence déloyale notamment en
luttant contre les délocalisations et
notamment en proposant encore une fois
de d'améliorer la vie quotidienne des
français parce que c'est ça que je veux
faire pour améliorer la vie quotidienne
des français voyez quand elle dit elle
parle du brevet sur les vaccins bon
c'est bien s'aimer c'est utopique ans a
été cette histoire portée par donc pour
préciser le brevet sur les vaccins c'est
un laboratoires comme pfizer qui pose un
brevet qui dit que le vaccin la recette
pour fait sur deux il lui appartient
alors que certains candidats à gauche
notamment propose la levée des brevets
pour permettre une production par tous
les laboratoires mais le problème c'est
que c'est pas tellement le brevet c'est
la production qui pose un problème
justement et beaucoup de pays qui sont
des pays pauvres n'ont pas les chaînes
de production pour pouvoir produire les
vaccins donc ça ne règle pas le problème
deuxièmement si demain il ya un nouveau
variant qui arrivent il faut
éventuellement qui est à nouveau vaccin
qui puisse être différent et je suis
désolé mais moi je n'ai pas confiance
dans les laboratoires se sont pas des
organismes humanitaires si vous leur
dites c'est pas vous allez faire des
recherches et en fait on va vous prendre
degré ça ils ne feront plus de recherche
donc le rapid vaccin donc c'est vraiment
du prototype si vous voulez des fausses
bonnes idées concernant la retraite à 60
ans elles se trompent nathalie arthaud
parce que précisément la réforme que
j'ai présentée ce matin d'ailleurs est
une réforme qui vise précisément à
permettre à ceux qui rentrent jeunes sur
le marché du travail de pouvoir sortir
jeunes voilà ce que le résumé est clair
plus on travaille jeune plus on
travaille dur plus on part tôt c'est à
dire que tous ceux qui sont entrés sur
le marché du travail entre 17 et 20 ans
auront partiront à la retraite à 60 ans
avec 40 annuités aujourd'hui je vous
signale qu'on est à 42 ans 42 annuités
62 ans et bientôt quarante trois
annuités 60 3 en 1 c'était donc votre
réponse à nathalie arthaud sur ce sujet
là de la même façon je vous propose de
poser une question à un autre candidat
en l'occurrence à jean luc mélenchon le
candidat de gauche de la france en
soumises pour ce faire vous avez une
caméra juste ici c'est la droite je vous
invite à poser votre question jean luc
mélenchon vous exprimer un intérêt non
dissimulé pour l'environnement aee
nous le concevons tous parce que c'est
une planète dont il s'agit mais pour le
coup je ne comprends pas du tout votre
position sur le nucléaire le nucléaire
est aujourd'hui précisément l'élément de
production d'une énergie décarbonée ces
mêmes l'énergie la plus décarbonée donc
pourquoi s'opposer à ce point au
nucléaire qui est peu chère qui permet
justement de l'électricité peu cher et
qui est une industrie qu'on maîtrise sur
le bout des doigts on va passer à la
prochaine question pour cela du coup la
roue se relancer vous pouvez l'arrêter
quand vous le souhaitez on va tomber sur
un emoji
les mauges et vidéos d'ailleurs c'était
maugis vidéo face cachée logiquement on
va découvrir une vidéo on va donc la
regarder ensemble est pareil on en parle
juste après l'europe sera au coeur de la
prochaine campagne présidentielle
comme vous le savez j'appelle depuis
2013 à un référendum du même type que
celui qui a eu lieu au royaume uni ce
référendum sur l'appartenance de la
france à l'union européenne est une
nécessité démocratique
les français doivent pouvoir choisir eux
aussi cette voie de liberté qui rendra à
la france sa pleine et entière
souveraineté
cet extrait c'est ce que vous disiez en
2016 au moment de la campagne pour la
dernière élection présidentielle vous
étiez favorable à l'époque à une sortie
de la france de l'union européenne
d'abord c'était une sortie ensuite en
2017 vous avez proposé un référendum
pour la sortie la france de l'union
européenne un freak site en quelque
sorte par le biais d'un référendum un
peu comme l'ont fait les britanniques
avec le bric site aujourd'hui en 2022
vous ne voulez plus que la france quitte
l'union européenne ni même organiser de
référendum sur une éventuelle sortie en
cas ce n'est pas dans votre programme
aujourd'hui pourquoi ce revirement sur
l'une de vos positions majeures bas
simplement parce que je pense que
l'union européenne déjà abandonné toute
une partie de ses dogmes notamment les
critères de maastricht est finie on n'en
parle plus les politiques d'austérité
qui ont été des conséquences c'est fini
mais parce que c'était inapplicable tout
simplement qu'on avait raison de me
critiquer mais je pense qu'aujourd'hui
avec les alliés que nous avons en europe
on a la possibilité de changer l'union
européenne pour la transformer en
alliance européenne les nations c'est à
dire on a la possibilité politiquement
en s'organisant de retirer des pouvoirs
à l'union européenne qui en a beaucoup
trop pour les rendre aux nations et donc
au peuple par exemple sur quel quel type
de choses peuvent revenir bas mais
plutôt qu'à l'union européenne bah
typiquement par exemple sur
l'immigration l'union européenne est en
train de s'attribuer des pouvoirs dans
ce domaine je pense que c'est aux
nations de les conserver en matière de
santé on a vu ce que l'union européenne
a fait c'est à dire n'importe quoi avec
les vaccins qui a cool qui ont coûté une
fortune et c'est nous encore une fois
qui payons la politique agricole
est en train en partie de se re
nationaliser c'est à dire que ce sont
les pays qui détermine les priorités
qu'elles donnent à leur politique donc
on va plutôt dans le bon sens et pas
suffisant je suis encore extrêmement
critique à l'égard de l'union européenne
mais je pense qu'il ya vraiment aimé les
moyens aujourd'hui de pouvoir faire
changer totalement cette cette
construction européenne donc vous voyez
une évolution se le voient à l'échelle
de l'union européenne ce qui fait que
vous souhaitez rester au sein d'union
européenne essayer de la changer on va
dire de l'intérieur d'une certaine façon
avec des alliés et d'autres pays
notamment on peut penser à la hongrie
vous avez un allié là bas avec viktor
orban sur un sujet plus précis avec la
question de l'euro aussi qu'ils avaient
un sujet majeur l'euro comme monnaie
vous aviez a déclaré notamment au
parisien le 30 avril 2010 est donc lors
de la dernière élection moi je pense que
l'euro est mort il faut maîtriser la
monnaie est elle adaptée à l'économie
parce qu'aujourd'hui la monnaie unique
est un boulet elle est en grande partie
responsable du chômage de masse même
question pourquoi ce revirement puisque
maintenant vous ne souhaitez plus sortir
de long et ça vous a pas échappé que
encore une fois l'ensemble des carcans
qui était posé sur cette monnaie ont
sauté par exemple ils ont commencé pour
sauver l'euro d'ailleurs ce que l'euro
était en difficulté pour sauver l'euro
qu'est-ce qu'ils ont été obligés de
faire ils ont été obligés de faire de la
création monétaire
énormément puisque l'on en est fraisse43
3000 milliards de création monétaire et
qu' ils ont abandonné en fait les
politiques d'austérité donc s'ils
voulaient cette monnaie aujourd'hui bon
elle n'est pas parfaite le moins qu'on
puisse dire c'est qu'elle continue à
avoir des inconvénients notamment dans
la compétition avec l'allemagne mais
elle ne représente plus le même niveau
si vous et de d'inconvénients de bon en
plus les français ont dit on veut pas
voilà j'ai un moment donné la démocratie
c'est aussi de ce sous de se soumettre à
ce que les français ne veulent pas ils
ne veulent pas sortir de l'euro ça leur
fait peur donc j'ai aussi tenu compte de
ça on dise on va écouter si vraiment
vous ne voulez pas senti à l'euro alors
on va faire avec et je pense honnêtement
qu'on peut faire avec on va passer à la
question suivante pour cela on relance
la route et je vous laisse à nouveau
arrêter cette roue
sur un et mogi un chronomètre vous le
voyez ici face cachée derrière ses
thèmes au jura découvrir tout simplement
une série de questions que je vais vous
poser c'est un exercice en général que
les candidats n'aime pas forcément j'en
suis bien conscient puisque il consiste
à répondre en une minute à un maximum de
questions en répondront par oui ou par
une mine atroce c'est souvent frustrant
puisque évitement ça permet pas
forcément de développer les idées mais
ça me semble un argument au delà des
autres questions et aussi du décryptage
du programme qu'on fait sur une autre
vidéo comme pour tous les candidats de
comprendre certains points précis de
votre programme est ce que vous êtes
prête oui doit-on supprimé le permis à
points
rapidement non
sauf pour les tombées tout pour les tout
petits excès de vitesse y at il
suffisamment de policiers en france non
faut-il rétablir l'uniforme à l'école
oui pour les petits faut-il rétablir la
peine de mort
prenant faire un référendum après chacun
dira oui ou non les violences policières
existe-t-elle
non systémiquement non le pass vaccinale
va-t-il être supprimés oui eric zemmour
pourrait-il être votre premier ministre
non les éoliennes sont elles utiles non
comptez-vous abroger la voix la loi
pardon sur le match pour tous non êtes
vous favorable à la pma pour tout
non est ce utile d'aller sur mars
vous pouvez la main 0 je ne sais pas
mais elle macron est-il selon vous le
pire président de la vème république oui
on a eu l'occasion d'en faire aux il me
reste une seconde on pose une dernière
dernière faut-il construire de nouvelles
centrales nucléaires oui et une de 2
pour terminer faut-il supprimer erasmus
non on a dépassé un petit peu le le
temps pour compenser les hésitations du
début là vous êtes favorable non
seulement un référendum sur la peine de
mort sur le rétablissement de la peine
de mort en france non je suis favorable
à ce que les français puissent par
l'intermédiaire d'un référendum
d'initiative populaire
déclenché des référendum et j'ai dit
s'ils veulent le déclencher là dessus et
interroger les français qu'ils le
fassent mais moi je ne le ferais pas
comme président de la république est
très concrètement comment ça se passera
ce référendum d'initiative
bao très clairement comme en italie
quand il ya 400 milles discutera 400 ou
500 mille signatures et bien le projet
de loi qui est soumis à référendum
et organiser enfin le référendum est
organisé à la demande des citoyens pour
permettre à l'ensemble du peuple
français de se positionner et ses 900 kg
semble possible que 400 mille citoyens
provoque comme ça un référendum sur la
peine de mort en france oui pourquoi pas
il faut pas avoir peur du peuple si le
peuple a des choses à dire qu'il est
qu'il les dise
moi je pense que le peuple doit toujours
avoir la possibilité d'intervenir dans
la politique pour faire entendre sa voix
moi je vous suis désolé mais le enfin
vous êtes très jeune très jeune mais en
2005 ne fait que les français aient voté
non à la constitution européenne les
roses et je considère que c'est un acte
anti démocratique majeur et à titre
personnel vous êtes favorable au
rétablissement de la peine de mort dans
sharepoint lutter on va passer à la
question suivante
est pareil je vous laisse du coup arrêté
ce
7 e roux qui va s'arrêter soir des
bougies c'est une date en l'occurrence
faire un calendrier on va voir
concrètement ce qui se cache derrière on
peut l'affiché tout de suite
ces quatre dates alors si tu me promet
un petit question et je lutte aussi ceux
qui regardent à essayer de deviner
quatre dates qui ont un élément en
comment est ce que vous arrivez à
trouver le point commun entre ces quatre
dates un événement qui se seraient
déroulés à ces quatre dates ce sont des
dates auxquelles il ya des référendum en
france ah oui il me parlait d'ailleurs
de 2005 bien sûr pourquoi est-ce qu'on
en parle ici puisque a donc le dernier
référendum en date et de 2005 si vous
êtes élue présidente de votre côté votre
première mesure ce serait de proposer un
référendum sur l'immigration pourquoi
faire
parce que ça fait 40 ans que les
français n'ont pas été interrogés sur
l'immigration or ce sont des gens qui
viennent
quelles sont les conditions pour qu'ils
viennent quelles sont les conditions
pour qu'ils restent quelles sont les
conditions pour devenir français je
pense que tout ça ça appartient en fait
aux français c'est sait comment est ce
qu'on vient et comment est ce qu'on vit
dans la maison commune france quand on
est étranger je pense est aux français
de décider mais concrètement ça
consistera en quoi cela consiste en un
projet de loi parce qu'en fait c'est
jamais une question les gens y pensent
qu'un référendum c'est une question oui
ou non non c'est un projet avec un peu
voilà c'est un projet de loi sur lequel
on vote oui ou sur lequel on vote non et
donc c'est un projet de loi dans lequel
je rends en fait aux français
la maîtrise de la politique
migratoires je rends les migrations plus
difficile plus exigeantes je rend
l'accès à la nationalité plus exigeante
parce que je pense qu'on a bradé tout
cela alors que c'est évidemment
important et très concrètement au sein
de cette loi dont vous parlez qu'est ce
que vous envisagez un train de mesures
très concrètes sur ce sujet de
l'intégration par exemple très
concrètement on va renvoyer chez eux les
délinquants étrangers ou les criminels
étrangers à la sortie de prison ils
repartiront c'est une mesure dont on
parlait tout à l'heure par exemple je
vais mettre en place la suppression du
droit du sol parce que je pense que la
nationalité française et ses rites par
l'intermédiaire de ses parents ou de
hans et de parents mais où elle se
mérite mais elle peut pas devenir une
acquisition automatique de la
nationalité au motif qu'on est né
quelque part on aurait la nationalité
automatique c'est aussi une manière de
rendre du contenu à la nationalité
française parce qu'il ya beaucoup de
jeunes qui ont la nationalité française
il voit pas la différence ce que ça leur
apporte de plus que ceux qui ne l'ont
pas et c'est aussi donc la mise en
oeuvre de la priorité nationale au
logement social et aux et au travail qui
est intégrée dans ce référendum sur ce
sujet là où il ya un traitement
l'article 11 de la constitution
aujourd'hui en france qui explique sur
quoi peut porter un référendum en france
et cet article 11 indique qu' il doit
porter sur l'organisation des pouvoirs
publics ou sur des réformes relatives à
la politique économique sociale ou
environnementale de la nation par
ailleurs certains principes énoncés
nombreux juristes estiment qu'ils sont
contraires aux traités européens il ya
donc un doute sur la possibilité de
faire un référendum sur le sujet de
l'immigration avec cette constitution
mais aussi un doute sur
l'incompatibilité de certaines mesures
notamment sur la priorité nationale par
rapport aux traités européens qui sont
existants aujourd'hui c'est une question
que posent de nombreux juristes sur un
tel référendum sur certaines de ces
mesures
je vais leur répondre d'abord pour leur
dire que la police d'immigration c'est
également une politique économique une
politique sociale parce que
l'immigration il confessé sur la seconde
a profité notamment de protection
sociale gok il ya aucun doute sur la
la légitimité de juridique de ce
référendum et c'est à certains je les
sens du cantal un conte winos enfin
certains
fall et certains juristes qui nous
explique c'est qu'ils n'ont pas lu le
projet de loi parce que dans le projet
de loi il est indiqué précisément qu'il
ya toute une série de règles qui sont
constitutionnaliser justement c'est à
dire c'est une réforme constitutionnelle
donc et dont un qui est très important
qui est un article qui vient dire le
droit ou international ou européen qui
est contraire à la constitution sera
inapplicable en droit français vous
voyez un ver serait selon vous la passe
que pour bien situer un peu le débat sur
ce sujet qui risque d'ailleurs de
revenir dans cette campagne
présidentielle aujourd'hui dans une
situation où les lois européennes prime
sur la loi française c'est à dire que
s'il ya une loi qui est adoptée à
l'échelle européenne elle doit ensuite
s'appliquer dans tous les pays de
l'union européenne et notamment en
france de l'autre côté votre objectif
donc ce serait de pouvoir inverser cela
si je comprends bien ce que vous dites
oui c'est à dire que je rends à la
constitution française sa primauté sur
le droit européen si le droit européen
ou international est contraire à la
constitution française qui a donc été
validé par référendum par le peuple
français alors les dispositions qui sont
contraires ne s'applique pas en dhr d'un
certain estime que vient sa exploserait
la france à des sanctions on voit le
débat d'ailleurs avec d'autres pays
européens aujourd'hui d'avoir une
incompatibilité entre les changements et
la constitution française est là ce
droit européen la question s'est posée
notamment en pologne résumé la question
qui se pose c'est quelle est la
légitimité des juges européens pour
imposer à un peuple des choses qu'ils ne
souhaitent pas c'est une vraie question
quand on en revient mais on revient la
question de l'appartenance à l'union
européenne ue ligue à tort mais on en
revient à la question de la souveraineté
des nations et à la question principale
de l'europe est ce que ceux qui ont créé
l'europe ont voulu supprimer au peuple
leur capacité à être souverain et à
décider de leur avenir et de la maîtrise
de leur destin moi je ne le crois pas je
crois que c'est une dérive sur et ses
bureaucrates on leur a donné un pouvoir
et puis au fur et à mesure ils
grignotent des pouvoirs et grignote des
pouvoirs grignote des pouvoirs au point
que ils cherchent à contrarier en fait
la volonté du peuple qui ne peut plus
décider pour lui-même pour moi cette
situation n'est pas admissible
donc à partir du moment où les français
auront voté ce référendum est bien la
constitution française sera supérieure
en droit aux textes européens et ce sera
comme ça et si ça déplaît à l'union
européenne tant pis tant pis tant pis
mais il y aurait des sanctions au super
il y aura des sanctions ben ça tombe
bien parce qu'on paye 9 milliards de
plus chaque année que ce qu'on touche
voyez donc ils peuvent toujours mettre
des sanctions il ya aucune difficulté on
les paiera en déduisant ces sanctions de
ce que nous versons à l'union européenne
en supplément de ce que nous touchons
parce que nous sommes contributeurs nets
au budget de l'union européenne dans des
proportions qui sont de plus en plus
importante par ailleurs voiture a
clairement on le voit sur cette mesure
d'ailleurs sur d'autres qu'on a pu
évoquer tout à l'heure des vrais enjeux
d'un point de vue juridique et de droit
par rapport à l'union européenne et ça
risque de revenir aussi dans le dans le
débat ici par ailleurs pour terminer sur
ce sujet là vous avez évoqué la notion
de priorité nationale c'est un terme que
vous utilisez souvent très concrètement
selon vous qu'est ce que ça veut dire et
comment est-ce que ça se traduit en deux
mots n'a par exemple pour le logement
social très concrètement
s'il y a des demandeurs français de
nationalité française à un logement
social et qu'il y à des demandeurs
étrangers un logement social c'est celui
qui est français qui a la priorité
d'accès au logement social ça fait
partie justement de ces mesures qui sont
contestés comme étant possible a ajouté
dans un référendum puisque certains
disent que ces éléments là ne peuvent
pas être soi sont contraires aux traités
européens soient sont contraires à la
constitution et à susciter une réforme
constitutionnelle
donc ils seront plus contraire à la
constitution puisque leurs efforts à la
navigation sûre on a changé la
constitution il faut modifier la
constitution et pour faire pour modifier
la constitution en tant que tel il faut
soit faire un référendum soit avoir
l'accord du parlement donc ça se fera en
deux temps si je comprends bien il ya
d'abord la réforme de la constitution
non non pas du tout le projet de loi
sur l'immigration qui sera votée par
référendum comporte une partie de
réforme constitutionnelle d'un coup on
change la constitution et on change le
nom n'est pas sur les versions orales et
les détails sur tous ces éléments ont
été rédigées vous pouvez d'ailleurs le
projet vous devez vous pouvez d'ailleurs
la trouver sur le sur notre site vous
avez l'intégralité du projet de loi qui
est déjà rédigé on s'est bien renseigné
sur votre programme on va passer à la
question suivante
du coup on relance la roue et je vous
invite à appeler une nouvelle fois
et c'est un graphique c'est pas les mots
dits le plus drôle de vue vu comme ça ce
graphique mais concrètement derrière
sable on va voir un graphique et on va
essayer de le lire ensemble c'est un
graphique qui indique la près des
préoccupations des jeunes de 18 à 29 ans
et issu d'une enquête d'ipsos réalisé
pour france inter en octobre dernier où
on a demandé donc à des jeunes de 18 à
29 ans quels étaient les enjeux leur
principale préoccupation les enjeux les
plus importants selon eux qui les
préoccupe le plus à titre personnel vous
le voyez on a caché la deuxième
préoccupation selon cette enquête est ce
que vous arrivez à deviner quelle est la
deuxième préoccupation majeure des
jeunes selon cette enquête on va donc en
première position pouvoir d'achat et
ensuite d'autres d'autres sujets quel
est le seul c'est pas comme ça je dirais
l'emploi parce que je le vois nulle part
et que c'est une colère parce que c'est
toujours les jeunes c'est vrai mais
j'imagine qu'il est regroupé sur la
question du pouvoir d'achat d'une façon
ou d'une autre est ce qu'on voyait autre
chose que le pouvoir d'achat s'est passé
exactement le même que que l'emploi donc
à l'orias question de l'emploi en
l'occurrence c'est pas celui ci mais ça
pourrait se pourrait l'être mais qui ont
surtout qu'on en a parlé tout à l'heure
le second sujet en l'occurrence c'est
l'environnement selon selon cette
enquête qui de fait est un enjeu qui est
majeur pour beaucoup de boxe française
pour la france en général je me suis
plongée forcément dans votre livre et
programmes que l'on pour trouver du coup
sûr votre album parce qu'il n'est pas
encore sorti celui sur l'écologie alors
c'est juste une question que j'allais
vous posez sur votre livret programme
principal disons qui est celui
disponible sur votre site internet en
plus des livres et thématiques vous
allez 22 mesures portées pour 2022 sur
votre site internet et sous un format
pdf sur ces différentes pages et ses
différentes mesures le mot environnement
ne figure pas le mot écologie n'ont plus
le mot climat non plus le mot
biodiversité non plus tous ces mots ne
figurent pas dans ce livret principal
avec vos 22 mesures principales on voit
pourtant que c'est une préoccupation
majeure des jeunes pourquoi est ce que
ces mots ne sont pas dans ce programme
parce qu'en réalité c'est trans
thématique l'environnement ça que l'on
parle pas environnement environnement
mais en l'environnement quand on parle
de relocalisation de l'activité parce
que par définition avoir une activité le
plus près produire plus près et
retraités sur place c'est de
l'environnement lorsqu'on parle de la
lutte contre les importations
frauduleuses par exemple on parle
environnement on parle d'ailleurs santé
alimentaire parce que quand on ne
respecte pas il ya des importations qui
respectent pas les normes que nous nous
sommes choisis qui sont des normes de
santé publique et bien c'est évidemment
notre sécurité sanitaire qui est en jeu
on parle environnement quand on parle
des métropolisation par exemple on parle
environnement
quand on parle d'énergie mais cette
démesure sur l'énergie qui sera mon avis
les meilleures mesures mais ont protégé
lors ça peut paraître étonnant que ces
mots là ne figure pas même
symboliquement que sur les veaux 22
principale mesure est le détail que vous
en faites sur chacune d'entre elles sur
ce programme ces mots-là environnement
biodiversité écologie climat ne figure
pas dans votre programme vous voyez vous
avez beaucoup de responsables politiques
qui ne cesse de balancer ses mots comme
ça dans le débat mais qui en réalité
font des propositions qui n'ont aucune
valeur vocation à régler le problème de
l'environnement et moi je considère que
le problème de l'environnement c'est le
propre du modèle économique je veux dire
tant qu'on ira acheter à 10000 que le
maître pour venir
consommer dix mille kilomètres plus loin
tant qu'on enverra des cargos monstrueux
qui polluent comme c'est pas possible eh
bien et qu'on n'aura pas changé
l'intégralité de ce modèle là on ne
règlera pas le problème de
l'environnement donc commençons à
regarder jeu qui est sous nos yeux s'ils
voulaient l'environnement c'est un peu
le magasin c'est un peu le l'éléphant
mieux de la pièce
tout le monde le voit mais en réalité on
quelque sorte en ligne hors parce qu'on
le détache des fêtes de des choix
économiques non contre les commerces de
choix économie et sur ce sujet justement
et sur vos prises de position là-dessus
le 9 mars 2021 vous êtes donc c'était il
ya tout juste un an dans la foulée de la
convention citoyenne pour le climat vous
aviez formulé une proposition l'idée
d'un référendum avec quinze questions à
poser aux français portant justement sur
l'environnement il y avait des questions
sur le nucléaire les questions sur les
éoliennes donc pour coup le sujet des
énergies la question des grandes
surfaces aussi qui était évoqué un
référendum dont tous les français
allaient décider sur ces questions là
aujourd'hui ce référendum il est absent
de votre programme en tout cas des 22
principales mesures vous n'en parlez
plus beaucoup voire plus du tout aussi
aujourd'hui est ce que vous portez
toujours cet objectif derrière sur
l'environnement mais bien sûr on peut
pas tout mettre si vous voulez on est en
train de parler de toutes les mesures
que nous devons faire pour changer la
situation de la france on ne peut pas
tout mettre dans les 22 on peut faire le
choix de faire de faire figurer les
questions environnementales ce sujet là
par exemple une fois malige les sujets
environnementaux ou les retrouverez
partout partout dans à chaque fois que
quand on parle localisme n'ont fait on
fait de l'environnement c'est de
l'environnement quand on part
aménagement du territoire ont fait de
l'environnement quand je propose que par
exemple les jeunes et des places
gratuites dans les trains aux heures
creuses voyez qu'ils puissent de 18 à 25
ans voyager comme ils veulent
gratuitement sur tous les thèmes france
mais aux heures creuses bah ça je suis
désolé mais c'est par exemple une mesure
environnement donc je suis les on en
fait peut-être moins une publicité que
d'autres mais je pense que nos mesures
pour l'environnement sont extrêmement
sérieuse parce qu'elles vont avoir une
conséquence concrète et un petit mot sur
sept ce référendum dont aviez parlé il
ya il ya un an parce que c'est forcément
un sujet majeur sur ces questions là
quelles seraient les grandes questions
posées dans le cadre de ce référendum
sur l'environnement compte est jalousé
précédent test qui sera rédigé il ya un
an même les commerçants s'étaient mises
en place je sais qu'il est toujours il
est toujours d'actualité moi je pense
que c'est intéressant d'interroger
d'ailleurs y compris en termes de
consultations d'interroger les gens sur
qu'est ce qu'il pense de tel ou tel
sujet d'abord parce que quand on crée
quand on met en place un infernal c'est
comme pour la constitution européenne ça
permet d'avoir un débat c'est à dire que
les français se font dire sa tribu en
fait ces sujets et qu' on puisse en
débattre pourquoi je vous dis ça parce
que il ya beaucoup de jeunes qui pensent
par exemple que le nucléaire c'est une
énergie qui crée du co2 beaucoup à
l'encré très peu voilà oui mais d'accord
mais ça veut dire que si on pose pas ce
sujet là est bien le débat n'a pas lieu
et alors les jeunes par exemple ne
peuvent pas savoir précisément ce qu'il
en est scientifiquement du nucléaire et
je pense que c'est très important qu'ils
le sachent pas ce que beaucoup sont anti
nucléaire parce qu'ils pensent que c'est
une énergie polluante on va passer une
dernière question
vous arrêtez la route directement avec
le buzzer on va voir sur toi ça sur quoi
ça arrête c'est le drapeau français
alors sous forme d maugis du coup il
n'est pas en rectangle il ya une autre
une autre forme mais c'est en
l'occurrence une question qui est posée
à chaque fois pour tous les candidats
que je reçois ici à l'occasion de cette
élection présidentielle
derrière c'était maugis vous allez
découvrir en fait des phrases a complété
ses phrases à compléter elles sont
inspirées d'un discours que vous
connaissez sans aucun doute c'est
discours de françois hollande qui avait
été prononcée face à nicolas sarkozy
lors du débat d'entre deux tours en 2012
le fameux mois prises dans qui ensuite
étaient complétées par françois hollande
à l'époque souffre donc de lire les
phrases qui vont s'afficher à l'écran et
de compléter en une phrase à chaque fois
avec évidemment vos propres mots on va
commencer avec première phase mois
présidente vous laisse compléter les
jeunes seront la priorité de mon
quinquennat la suivante mon poids et
mini sera vous le serez le lendemain du
second tour
mon prise et que c'est comme emmanuel
macron et dans le coffre de la voiture
ce que vous souvenez qu'il a émis
edouard philippe dans le coffre de sa
voiture le suivant dans le coffre de la
voiture pour ceux qui n'ont pas le
contexte soit il avait mis hui s'étaient
rencontrés il s'était caché dans le
coffre de la voiture pour aller
rencontrer emmanuel macron je n'ai pas
la réponse de cette présidence un an et
demi sera l'islamisme la suivante moi ma
première visite officielle sera à
bruxelles pour leur expliquer que ça va
pas être pareil qu'avant et la dernière
- présidente la france est ma passion
merci beaucoup marine le pen d'avoir
accepté si cet échange pour mieux
comprendre bien votre programme est
votre vision de la france c'est un
format qu'on fait du coup avec tous les
candidats à l'élection présidentielle et
la même façon d'ailleurs comme pour tous
les candidats en plus de cette interview
on a eu l'occasion de passer en revue un
certain nombre de sujets ça a bien
accompagné d'une autre vidéo on va
décrypter votre programme sur cette même
chaîne youtube on suivra donc tout ça
merci et encore merci avant que c'était
à mon invitation et c'est donc la fin de
cette vidéo la merci d'avoir été si
nombreux à suivre jusqu'au bout
évidemment n'hésitez pas à vous abonner
à cette chaîne youtube si jamais ce
n'est pas encore le cas pour ne pas
louper toutes les interviews qui suivent
tous les décryptages aussi des
programmes qui suivent on continue à
suivre l'élection présidentielle en plus
des autres contenus qu'on fait au
quotidien sur d'autres sujets présentent
vous pourrez faire vos proches et on se
dit ah très vite